Let's go next to where do we want to go next?
There are so many different people.
Oh, you know who I want to go to?
Let's go to our friend and read Gift from
Los Angeles, calling from the three to three.
We haven't heard from him for ten.
Can you believe that it's been 10 months since
we heard from you?
It's been ten months.
Yeah.
Wow.
It feels like yesterday.
I know what's going on.
Hey, I was I was watching your jaw open.
The lesson or jaw organ?
Yeah, I mean, I. Oh, it was amazing.
And I love watching you talk to people at
your organs.
Just really quick.
Yeah, I just think, oh, Uncle Kolinsky.
I totally I didn't want to say anymore.
It really upset me that he said that he won't
vote provided.
Did he just say.
Did he say that or did he say.
Unless Biden comes around on at least a couple
of his five most important issues.
He said he's not voting for him.
He's just not going to vote for Biden.
Oh, I did.
And, you know, that might make the latest
you heard.
And I apologize.
You know, I'm I haven't looked at Twitter
replies for five days.
As I mentioned, the last I heard was Kyle
would vote for him if Biden conceded or compromised
on two of Kyle's top five issues.
When I heard him, he said he said, blame me
for Trump's next win.
That's what he said.
You can blame me and I'm okay with that.
OK, so I don't know.
Yes, but I was going to tell you.
So I just think, again, that the left man,
I'm so worried about this election, the left
really needs to pull it together again.
The reason I'm Melissa is a couple linsky.
Why is it that the left can not can not even
with a threat like Trump is destroying this
country?
You cannot come together.
Why?
How come the Republicans can get behind a
man as a moral, as corrupt, a thief, a con
artist like Trump.
But we can't get behind together for someone
like Biden.
Yes.
I think Biden is not the best.
But come on.
And it just infuriates me.
And also.
The left is so weak at speaking to its voters.
I think it is a lesson.
Those are 10, 10 months ago.
But why are we not showing videos of how Trump
is like a dictator or how he's destroying
the justice system, how he's putting judges
that are going to vote his way, how he is
obstructing justice?
I mean, why are we not letting Americans know?
Well, what do we get when we say when you
say, why aren't we showing the videos?
Who is we are like, are you talking about
CNN?
Or you talk like, who are you talking about?
I'm talking about.
OK.
I guess the DNC, I guess the people that are
trying to get him elected, that are working,
getting paid to get him elected.
Why are they not showing?
Why are they not stronger?
I think the left is so weak right now.
I had a conversation with my brother yesterday.
He's like, Rick, I'm so mad at the Democrats
right now.
But of course, I'm able.
I'm very conservative, hard core Christian
conservative values.
You vote liberal and I'm like, yeah, that's
true.
We're so weak.
So let's.
So here's the main thing I want to address
that you mentioned.
Why does the right seem to unite around their
candidate when the left sometimes does not?
I think that this has a lot to do with the
left having more acceleration, its tendencies
and more opposition to incrementalism, whereas
the right, if they've got a guy who talks
about grab them by the pussy, has been married
three times, was pro-choice up until, you
know, six months before he ran for president.
If he says, I'll put people on the court,
that will be against abortion.
That the Heritage Foundation or whoever suggests
to me and I'll put in the right judges.
That's what they care.
They'll take it.
They'll take they.
They're like, hey, we're gonna get something
here.
We're not going to get that with Hillary.
We're certainly not going to do anything that
helps Hillary get elected.
Let's put Trump in.
And you know what?
Now, another Trump fist president is not completely
unlikely.
It's possible that now you could get another
right winger at some point.
The left has a larger portion of its makeup,
that is people.
And I want to be clear, I'm not talking about
Kyle now.
He has said he's not an acceleration, as I
want to be clear about that.
You have more people on the left who are not
missing the forest for the trees.
They only care about the forest, so to speak.
And when they see, hey, Biden gets you pick
a number, 70 percent of what, Burton, he gets
you 65.
I don't know what the number is, whereas Trump
gets you less than zero.
They say we don't care.
You know, maybe we want to teach the DNC a
lesson or I'm not going to vote for a guy
who 20 years ago said he would be open to
policies that he is certainly not running
on now or whatever the case.
So when you have more acceleration ism in
your political theory, you will see less of
of a sort of coming together to eliminate
the greater evil or the evil, as I call it.
And as you call it.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, and Reka, you're breaking up,
so I'm gonna let you go, you're coming in
all choppy like you're on a submarine, but
I'm gonna let you go.
I so appreciate hearing from you.
We have Enrique Amarth is a good caller.
Good caller.
And Peka from L.A.. Let's take a quick break.
Don't hang up if you're holding, because I
will go right back to the phone.
It's going to be incredible.